would you rather a be permanently hung  over or b  never be able to drink again oh you love  that tequila oh man i i mean gotta hang  what's that when you get a mean hangover  though and when you you guys you'll see  when you get older [ __ ] it's a mean one  to get over like i used to be able to  party  i remember a party all night two three  more get up still work out boom go about  my day now i can go hard and i need like  three to recover yeah three to like fine  to feel normal again  i don't know if i could be permanently  hungover i'll be honest with you that i  just be miserable i'd just be miserable  i might not be able to drink again i'd  i'd substitute it with other substances  if i had to these are hypothetical these  are hypothetical